gold on the other hand
there were certain markers you looked at
hey inflation is up you know hey
interest rates are going up hey we're
printing money hey they're printing more
money hey they're sending more money out
gold would typically there would be a
reaction to it right now that is more of
a reaction towards crypto and Bitcoin
where it's no longer the reaction
towards gold why do you think that's
happened to gold
I think Gold's getting uh demonetized by
Bitcoin right now if you look at the
past three years since my microstrategy
bought 250 million dollars worth of
bitcoin in August of 2020.
since that time bitcoin's up about 140
percent uh the s p is up about 20
percent nasdaq's up 10 goals up one
percent Silver's down about eight
percent bonds are down 18
conclusion right if you if you buy debt
govern government debt you're going to
be bankrupt that's why those banks are
going bankrupt all the banks had had
debt when the interest rates went
through the roof the debt traded down
and they all were technically insolvent
um the problem with uh gold
is first of all if you have if I bought
250 million dollars worth of gold I
can't like carry it around in my pocket
I can't take self-custody of it I can't
move it anywhere I can't transfer it to
a counterparty and so that means I have
to put it in a bank there's only a
handful of banks in the world that
custody it and the banks rehypothecate
the gold so that means that if you
wanted to sell 250 million dollars of
gold the bank will will sell your gold
if you want to buy it they'll sell you
paper and the paper gold isn't backed by
the actual gold so
you have fractional Reserve banking of
gold
right that's that uh you don't want to
own an asset where the bank can sell a
hundred acts more of that asset than
they own
that the whole problem with uh fiat
currency right if you look at the
history of banking it was you know
goldsmiths
you know goldsmiths have gold when gold
was money and they gave you a note so
you give me a million dollars of gold I
give you a million dollar note you trade
the notes back and forth that's your
paper money that works fine as long as
it's a one-to-one
but then the guy that's the Goldsmith
says holy crap I actually can give him a
million dollar note and he thinks that
I've got a million dollars of gold
backing it and now there's two million
in the system and then I give him a
million dollars and now there's three
million in the system now there's three
times as much money there's one stack of
gold worth a million bucks prices go
through the roof that's inflation and
eventually you come back and you try to
redeem your paper for the stack I give
you your goal back and you try to redeem
and the Gold's gone and you try to
redeem and the Gold's gone okay I'm
bankrupt oops
okay so when did this idea of of over
issuing paper money start
didn't start if you know when Nixon
defaulted on the gold standard he wasn't
the first he was just the most famous
right people have been defaulting on
paper money probably for thousands of
years and Nixon just made it official
yeah so so the issue is if gold is money
and it goes into a bank the bankers
issue 10x more more paper than there is
gold you have inflation eventually right
when the French tried to redeem their
their paper dollars for gold the U.S
basically closed the gold window we
defaulted on on uh that obligation and
we started a cycle of inflation from
1971 on that's been running 50 years now
when FTX failed it was no different the
issue was people put Bitcoin on FTX and
then Sam turned around and issued three
acts as much paper you know obligations
and when people try to withdraw the
Bitcoin he doesn't have it he fails when
Silicon Valley Bank failed
or when when any of these other bank
fails they had certain amount of money
you know and then they turned around and
they and they invested it and their
investment was in government securities
the Securities traded down now they were
insolvent when people try to withdraw
their money they don't actually have the
money to pay them off the banks fail so
when you look at this banking crisis
what's going on what you've got is a
bunch of banks everywhere in the world
that have shaky assets
right what what's what's really shaky
well if if you actually hold Argentine
pesos or or in Nigerian naira and then
you triple the supply of them every year
the value goes to zero right if that's
your currency base or your asset base
you're going to be insolvent when P when
people put 10 billion dollars into a
bank backed by pesos
the peso goes to zero the bank turns
around and reloans out 20 billion
dollars now there's 30 billion dollars
circulating on 10 billion dollars in the
bank when you try to withdraw the money
the bank collapses the entire economy
collapses that's going on everywhere in
the world uh it's much worse in Lebanon
or Nigeria or in Argentina than it is in
the U.S
it's bad in the U.S uh but and it's
cracking on the seams with you know
First Republic Bank and Silicon Valley
Bank and Signature Bank and and the like
but uh what do you conclude if you're an
individual
if you're just uh if you're a company or
if you're a family or if you're an
individual and you live
in Zimbabwe what would you do
well you can't you're not going to buy
gold and put in the bank the bank's just
going to seize your gold you're not even
going to buy dollars and put it in the
bank the bank is going to seize your
dollars you're not going to buy local
Zimbabwe dollars they're going to zero
as you stare at them they're going to
lose
10 of their value a month right they're
just melting in your hand so you got to
buy something you can custody so before
Bitcoin you would have bought bars of
soap crates of toilet paper you would
have bought motorcycles you would have
bought a Humvee you would have bought
barrels of oil you would have bought
anything you would bought food you would
have bought bullets you would have
bought guns anything tangible that you
can self-custody you would have held now
after Bitcoin you now have for the first
time in human history the ability to buy
not a barrel of oil but 80 worth of
bitcoin
and you put it on your phone
and now you can go through an airport
with the Bitcoin you can't go to there
through the airport with a barrel of oil
right and and you don't what's the big
the big difference the difference
between gold and Bitcoin and the reason
Bitcoin is up 140 percent and gold is up
one percent
is the middle class family can custody
their own Bitcoin and a wealthy person
can can either hold 10 million dollars
of Bitcoin and self-custody or if I live
in Africa I can move the 10 million
dollars of Bitcoin to Monaco Singapore
London Paris New York or Miami Beach and
that is not an option you have with your
gold it's not an option you have with
your dollars when you're an Argentine
Citizen and you actually called the bank
and say hey move my million dollars out
of Argentina and send it to Switzerland
they're like
I got us no no they have Capital
controls they have banking controls
the the people in Lebanon with millions
of dollars in Lebanese Banks they wanted
to get their money at Lebanon who was
like well sorry your funds are frozen
why because the bank never had the
million dollars as soon as you put the
million dollars in the bank in Lebanon
they turned around and loaned it to the
government
it's gone the government spent the
million dollars you try to get the money
out
the bank closes its doors right is that
illegal no because the guy that runs the
government passed a law declaring a bank
holiday for the good of the country
saying that we can't allow you to redeem
your dollars so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
foreign